هذا الامور الجميله جدا في التشاد انه
تخلص صغار مثلا اعمارهم ست سنوات سبع
سنوات يبنون مساجد صغيره من الطين وتجد
مجموعه من الاطفال يجعلون طفل منهم يا
امهم ويصلون خلف التراويح فصراحه
[موسيقى]
ما هي لغتكم في تشاد هل انتم مسلمون كثيرا
ما توجهوا هذه الاسئله للمغتربين تشاديين
في الدول العربيه ربما يرد تشاديون
باستغراب او استهجان فاغلبهم مسلمون
ولغتهم عربيه في هذه الحلقه سنضع العتاب
جانبا ونترك ضيفنا ياخذنا في رحله الى
هناك انا روعه وهذا بودكاست الجزيره بعد
امس اما ضيفنا فهو الاستاذ سعيد ابكر احمد
الباحث والكاتب التشادي مؤلف كتابه تشاد
جوهره في يد فحام لديكم
بدايه لنبدا من لليكم من اين اتى هذه
التحيات شاديه هل هي افريقيه هل هي عربيه
هل هي مزيج السلام عليكم في البدايه لا
لكم هي عباره عن ترحيبه
يعتقد انها حرفت كلمه السلام عليكم فاصبحت
لا عليكم فلما تكون في تشاد واحد من الناس
يقول لكم لا عليكم اهلا ومرحبا والسلام
عليكم او مرحبا
عليه بلا لينه ايوه
لاليكم لالينا خلاص حفظناها هذا يقودنا
الى سؤال قبل ان او بالاحرى قبل ان نتطرق
الى اللهجه التشاديه والتعابير فيها وجود
اللغه العربيه فيها اخبرنا بدايه عن تشاد
قصه هذا البلد قصه شعبه
اولا تشاد هي دوله تقع في قلب افريقيا قلب
افريقيا نابض حقيقه ليس قلب افريقي
كموقع جغرافي وانما ايضا كحضاره كثقافه
كتراث وجمهوريه تشاد تشكلت من مجموعه من
من الممالك الاسلاميه التي كانت موجوده
قبل ان يصل المستعمل الفرنسي او اولى هذه
الممالك اسمها مملكه كانم اسست في القرن
الثامن الميلادي القرن الثاني الهجري
ثم تاسست بعدها مملكه اسمها مملكه باجرمي
وهذه تاسست تقريبا في القرن الحادي عشر
الميلادي
واخيرا المالكه الاسلاميه التي تاسست هي
مملكه وداي وهذه الممالكه الاسلاميه
الثلاثه هي التي شكلت شاد الحديثه لانه
مملكه كان تقع في الشمال مملكه وداي تقع
في الشرق بالقرب من التخوم السودانيه
ومملكه باقرمي تقع في
الان العاصمه الجمعيه ايضا تعتبر تابعه
لمملكه باجرمي التي تعتبر عاصمتها ماسينيا
هذه ممالك ثلاثه تشكلت منها تشاد الحديثه
التي وصل اليها الفرنسيون في عام 1902
ودارت معركه شرسه ما بين القائد العسكري
رابح فضل الله مع القائد الفرنسي لاميه
وبعم 1900 بالضبط دخلت القوات الفرنسيه
الى تشاد وحتى عام 1920 تقريبا
استطاعت فرنسا ان تكون ان تحصل على جميع
الاراضي التشاديه عندما دخلت الى الشمال
لانه الشمال كانت منطقه صحراء شاسعه على
صحراء الكبرى وكانت منطقه جبليه فكانت في
اخر المناطق التي ضمها الاحتلال الفرنسي
عندما جاء الى يعني اغلب الموجودين في
تشاد اغلب التشاديين هم مسلمون ويتحدثون
باللغه العربيه
والاستعمار لم يدم طويلا تقنيا
لكنه كان عنيف جدا هم دخلوا 1900 وخرجوا
1960 يعني لكن كانت هناك يعني جرائم بحق
الشعب التشادي خاصه ما حدث في عام 1917
مذبحه مشهوره اسمها مذبحه الكبكب حين قام
الفرنسيون بقتل العلماء علماء مذبحه
الكبكب هي قصه ماساويه جدا كانت
وذبح الفرنسيون انذاك اكثر من 400 عالم
بالساطور وكانت صراحه جدا مجزره موجوده
حتى الان في التاريخ التشادي وتعتبر صفحه
سوداء من صفحات الاستعمار الفرنسي في
التشات يعني هذا العنف في الاستعمار لم
يكن فقط للثروات كان هناك محاوله غزو
ثقافي عندما يقتلون العلماء بالضبط كان
الهدف الاساسي هو الاستعمار الثقافي لان
العلماء كانوا يقاومون الاستعمار الثقافيا
فكان يطلبون يطلبون من الناس عالم الذهاب
الى المدارس الفرنسيه وكانوا يؤسسوه
للشريعه الاسلاميه وكانوا علماء علم شرعي
ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن متميزون
ومتبحرون طيب يعني كل دول المنطقه التي
خضعت للاستعمار تواجه احيانا ازمه هويه
بين اللغه لغه المستعمر وبين اللغه الام
ما هو واقع الهويه التشاديه اليوم
تعاني من ازمه هويه انا ذكرت ذلك في عاده
حتى في الجلسات او في الكتب التي يعني
نقراها انه في ازمه هويه في المجتمع
التشادي لانه الازمه الحقيقيه انه النخبه
التي درست باللغه الفرنسيه هي بسيطه جدا
لانه حاليا نسبه الاميه في تشاد حوالي 70%
اما 30% الاخرون بعضهم متعلم علم شرعي
وحتى الان اللغه الفرنسيه لم تستطع ان
تثبت كلغه شارع حتى الان بامكانك تذهب الى
تشاد ان تتحدثي مع اي شخص باللغه العربيه
تفهميه ويفهمك بصوره واضحه جدا اللغه
الفرنسيه هي لغه اداره فقط لغه اداره
حكوميه للتعامل الحكومي بعض النخب
السياسيه يتحدثونها لكن حتى الان ما
استطاعت ان تخترق المجتمع التشادي لانه
المجتمع الشادي عباره عن مجتمع في مجموعه
قبائل هذه القبائل قرابه الميتين قبيله
اختارت اللغه العربيه لكي تكون لغه
التواصل بينهم وهم يتحدثون باللغه العربيه
انا مثلا الان لغتي الام ليست عربيه لغه
اخرى لكن انا عندما اتحدث مع اي شخص اخر
في المجتمع التشادي اتحدث بعربيه اسمها
العربيه الدارجيه هي عربيه فيها لكن لهجه
محليه بسيطه
طيب ولكن بالاحصاءات العرب اقليه لماذا
هذا هل هو هذا واقع الحال حسب الارقام
الموجوده ان العرب اقليه في تشاد واذا ام
لا اما انكم مسلمون ولكن لستم عرب
الحقيقه اكبر قبيله من حيث العدد من
القبائل المسلمه هي قبيله العرب وهذا لا
اعرف الكثير انه اكبر بالفعل الجنوب عند
قبائل جنوبيه لكن ضمننا نحن كمسلمين اكبر
قبيله من حيث التعداد السكاني قبيله العرب
فالعرب ليسوا اقليه في تشاد هم اكثريه
ويتوزعون من شمال يعني من الطرف انهم
يتوزعون من اقصى الشرق منطقه عراضه حتى
الى العاصمه الجميله فكلهم يتوزعون فيها
ولديهم حواضر مشهوره جدا اما اتيمان اتيه
هذه كلها يقتلها تقتنها قبائل العربيه
يعني فهم اكثريه حاليا من حيث المسلمون
يعني اذا باعتبار جمله المسلمون الذين
تتشكل نسبتهم ب 75% اكبر قبيله من القبائل
المسلمه هي قبيله العرب
طبعا هذه الاحصاءات ليست دائما دقيقه في
دوله مثل تشاد لذلك طرحت السؤال حدثنا عن
اللهجه عربيه دارجه شاديه ماذا يعني ذلك
هل اذا ذهبت الى الان الى مثلا هل سيفهم
علي تشاديون او افهم عليهم
جدا من السودانيه لكن بس فيه بعض
المصطلحات الفرنسيه والى هي قريبه جدا من
السوداني يعني بامكانك ان مثلا انا الان
في التلفزيون التشادي توجد نشره نشره
اخباريه تكون في حوالي الساعه التاسعه
بتوقيت شات هنا تقريبا الساعه الحاديه
عشره ليلا اذا دخلت واستمعتي الى النشره
لن تواجه صعوبه في فهم الكلمات يعني اي
عربي فرانكفوني لن يجد مشكله في شوارع
يعني مثلا اذا اردت الان ان تقول لي مرحبا
كيف الحال اريد ان اذهب الى متجر
لشراء مثلا الخضار كيف تقولها باللهجه
التشاديه
يعني اقول لك مثلا كيف انت عافيه انا حاسه
حاليا يدور نمشي مقزه بدون نبيع حاجات
قاعد
مثل السوداني تقريبا من السودانيه يعني
كيف كيف
لا لينا
الحلقه مثل كلمات طيب خلينا نبقى في
انجمينا الان اجواء رمضان
والعيد كيف كيف تعيش تشاد او انجامينا
تحديدا رمضان والعيد جميله جميله جدا في
رمضان وفي العيد في رمضان عاده يعني
الناس تركز في شيئين الاساسيين في تشاد
اول شيء الافطار وصلاه التراويح والقيام
الافطار اكثرها سوائل لانه تعرف انك الشمس
ساخنه فالدول تكون فيها الشمس داخله
التركيز اكثر يكون على السوائل في شراب
اسمه الابره ابره نعم وفي الكركديه
وكذلك يعني
تاخذونها باردا نعم باردا الابره
مثل الخروب
ياخذونه ويجففونه حتى يصبح بعد ذلك
يخلطونه مع الماء البارد يشربونه يعني
ويضيفون عليه قليل من السكر رائحته زكيه
جدا يعني رائحته طيبه فحتى قبل موسم رمضان
عندما تكوني ماشيه في شوارع جنبنا تشمرين
هذه الرائحه الذكيه من البيوت جربت الخروب
الخروب لا ما جربته توقعاتي انه مثل
الخروب ولكن سنبحث في ذلك بعد الحلقه
سنذهب كنا نعزمك بعض الافطار
طيب الحساب مثلا هل تبقونا بالسوائل
البارده
نحن الخروف نعم لحم الخروف وبعد ده عندهم
عندنا الفيتشات فانقصوا فانقصوا عباره عن
اللقيمات اللي هي لقمه القاضي هذه نحنا
نسويها فانجاسو فانغاسو وكذلك الخبز
هذه كلها موجوده احيانا ايضا تكون هناك
اللوبيا اللوبيا ايضا مشهوره هناك يعني في
الافطار عاده وبعد كده النساء
بالطبخ فعندهم كده حاجات جميله جدا
يعملونها في الافطار
عبر العالم كلنا نحب الطبخ صراحه اعتقد في
العالم
طيب هناك فوانيس رمضان هناك
يعني هل هناك ايضا في الشارع زينه خاصه
برمضان
يعني تعرف حتى الاطفال الصغار يبنون مساجد
صغيره ويصلون فيها يعني هذه الامور
الجميله جدا في تشاد انه اطفال صغار مثلا
اعمار ست سنوات سبع سنوات يبنون مساجد
صغيره من الطين وتجد مجموعه من الاطفال
يجعلون طفل منهم يا امهم ويصلون خلف
التراويح صراحه
نعم بالضبط وايضا يبدعون في صلاه التراويح
وصلاه القيام واي طفل مثلا حفظ القران
الكريم موسم رمضان يكون موسم امتحان له
فيقدمونه ليصلي بالنصره التراويح حتى
يختبرون كفاءته واتقانه للقران الكريم
فاسلوب جدا جميل فالاطفال يتنافسون بينهم
ايهم اتقن لكتاب الله وايهم اكثر فهما
لمعانيه فيتنافسون في هذا الجانب كل واحد
منهم يريد ان يصلي
طيب على عندكم كعك العيد نعم اكيد هذا شيء
كعك العيد بسكويت في انواع مختلفه في
بسكويت
لا هو اشبه الكعكه الغرب السودان نفسه في
غرب السودان وشرق تشاد ونفس الكعك انك
يسموه كيك
واحيانا يقولوا كعك انا العيد
وعندنا ايضا في العيد من الطقوس الموجوده
انك عندما تصلي صلاه العيد تزور كل
الجيران يعني مش يصلي العيد وترجع البيت
لا الجيران كل سفهم ان كانوا حتى 100 جار
تمشي وتسلم عليهم رمضان عيد سعيد الله
يقدر لكم في عيالكم والله
كل عام وانتم بخير الله يحفظكم السماح
الله يتقبل منا الصيام وينجينا من كفارته
يعني ادعيه كلها لطيفه جدا انه الله
سبحانه وتعالى يتقبل منا صيامنا وقيامنا
ويبلغنا رمضان القادم فتمشوا تزوروا كل
البيوت واي بيت زر يعطوكم هديه العيد
عباره عن
وعصائر وحلويات فتزوره جميع الحي ثم
تعودون اخر شيء للبيت نفسها عصاير رمضان
او احيانا نفس عصائر رمضان وحيانا يعني
يبتكرون انواع اخرى ايضا من العصائر بحيث
تكون مع مناسبه العيد اعتقد في ليبيا كان
شراب اللوز يوم العيد
حتى في تشاد مثلا في يعني حاجات يعملوها
خصيصا عشان تعرف انه هذا موسم موسم العيد
حتى تكون طقوس المستعمله في عيد الفطر
تختلف عن طقوس الموجوده في عيد الاضحى
المبارك طيب في عيد الفطر وجبه الغداء
الرئيسيه ما هي الجميع الاسره المستطيعه
كلها تذبح
لانه هناك نحن عندنا الثروه الحيوانيه
موجوده بكثره فالجميع يعني كلهم استطاع
انه خلاص يقوم بوليمه في البيت ويدعوا
الجيران والمساكين والاصحاب والاصدقاء
وياتوا ويتغدون سويا بعد ذلك الفتره
المسائيه يقضونها في الدردشه والوانسه
فصراحه اجواء العيد جدا
اللغه العربيه تشهد فعليا تراجعا خصوصا من
الناحيه من جهه التعليم ما هو واقعها
اليوم
ولماذا لا يوجد اهتمام بها كما يجب مع
انها اللهجه الدارجه المحكيه والتي تربط
القبائل المختلفه بلهجاتها الام المختلفه
او بلغاتها الام المختلفه
انا وصلت الى قناعه انه اي دوله فيها
اللغه الفرنسيه لغه اساسيه من الصعب ان
تكون هناك ثنائيه لغويه وخير ما يمثل ذلك
دول شمال افريقيا حقيقه
سمويه الحصار اللغه العربيه هناك حاليا
تشاهدين اصبحت امالهم اكبر فاصبحوا بدل ان
اللغه العربيه حاليا احنا نفهمها ونقراها
سواء حتى الدرس باللغه الفرنسيه هو لديه
فتره مسائيه يقرا قران كريم معنا قراءه
القران الكريم انك خلص يعني انت تفهم
اللغه العربيه فاصبحوا الان يذهبون الى
اللغه الانجليزيه فبدل ما المدارس العربيه
كانت منتشره حاليا حتى الان الجهودها
مدارس العربيه كلها جهود اناس كانوا في
مصر وكانوا في الخليج العربي وعندما عادوا
الى تشاد اسسوا مدارسهم العربيه وقاموا
بجهود كبيره جدا خاصه اواخر التسعينات
وبدايه الالفيه واثبت وجاره جدارتهم حقيقه
وهناك ايضا جامعات ايضا حتى الان الجامعات
الحكوميه مثل جامعه الجمعيه لديها اقسام
باللغه العربيه وايضا في يعني مسؤولون
كبار جدا في الدوله التشاديه ايضا دارسين
باللغه العربيه وقد لا تكون لديهم درايه
باللغه الفرنسيه على فكره فحالي اللغه
العربيه واقعها بالفعل ما اقول انه واقع
ممتاز لكن حاليا الواقع في تحسن يعني
الواقع في تحسن والواقع ان شاء الله تعالى
اذا الناس اجتهدت واي احد منا قدم
مسؤوليته ورسالته واستطاع ان يقدم ما
يستطيع لخدمه اللغه العربيه وليس
الاستخدامها بامكانها ان يحقق يعني نجاح
في اللغه العربيه طيب اللغه الرسميه هي
فرنسيه وعربيه هل هناك لغتان للدوله ام
لغه وكم لغه في مجمل تشاد من اللغات
المحليه لكل قبيله هل هي كل قبيله ام هل
هي بالمناطق تقسم
في منطقه واحده قد تريد اكثر من قبيله هو
منطقه واحد تكون فيها خمسه قبائل سته
قبائل وكل قبيل لديها لهتها المعهوده لها
هناك مركز ايضا موجود في تشاد هذا مركز
وظيفته الاهتمام باللهجات المحليه ياخذها
وينظمها ويرتبها وان كانت على المساعي غير
حميده هو يعمل ذلك حتى يقلل من قيمه اللغه
العربيه لكن في النهايه خدمه حتى اللهجات
المحليه الاخرى حتى تكون مكتوبه وحتى تتم
العنايه بها وحتى يتم معرفه اللهجات هذه
من اين جاءت وكيفيه تداخل اللهجات مع
بعضها البعض ما بين القبائل لا نستطيع ان
نتعرف على بلد من دون ان نتعرف ايضا على
السياسه في نحن تركنا السياسه للاخر لان
كل ما سبق يجمع اكثر ربما تشاد تقدم
لعضويه جامعه الدول العربيه قبل سنوات
ولكن الى الان لا يوجد رد حول هذا الطلب
لماذا
اعتقد في القمه العربيه التي كانت في سرت
في ليبيا بعضويه لجامعه الدول العربيه
وهذه العضويه بالفعل كانت محل نقاش ثم
بعدما حدثت الاحداث في ليبيا توقف الملف
وحاليا صراحه انا وصلت الى قناعه لانه نحن
يعني حتى ولو من دون جامعه الدول العربيه
اما التعريف عندنا شاعر يقول اما التعريف
اذا سئلوا فافارقه ومن العرب نحن في
النهايه هويتنا العربيه الافريقيه نعتز
بها نعتز بها على مدار سنوات طويله جدا
في 2009 تم اختيار تشاد العاصمه تشاديه
وجمينا كعاصمه للثقافه الاسلاميه وتوافد
الوفود من كل مكان وتعجبوا من قوه اللغه
العربيه وحضورها في الشخصيه التشاديه
جامعه الدول العربيه هي كغطاء يظلنا جميل
جدا اذا كانوا يدنا فرصه لكن ما دام انه
الالتحاق بهذه الجامعه سبحان عصيرا فنحن
ايضا نركز على ذاتنا وان شاء الله تعالى
ما يمنع في يوم من الايام اننا نكون عضو
في جامعه الدول العربيه لكن حاليا اما
التعريفه اذا سئلوا فافارقه ومن العرب
يعني هذا اول بيت شعر احفظه انا عاده
صراحه اقدر جدا الاشخاص الذين لديهم
القدره على استحضار ابيات الشعر خلال
الكلام اقرا الشعر واسمع قليلا ولكن ليس
لدي هذه المهاره فانا جدا منبهره من ذلك
عندما تقولون يعني في التعريف افارقه ولكن
عرب بالمقابل ملف التطبيع مع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تشاد خطه خطوات كبيره لدرجه
انها فتحت سفاره هناك لماذا
اوكي نحن حقيقه
اول دوله من دول وسط افريقيا
طردت السفينه الاسرائيلي في 1971 هي
جمهوريه تشاد نحن موقفنا من القضيه
الفلسطينيه كان واضح من البدايه طلبنا
السفير الاسرائيلي شر طرده من المطار
وحيدا طريضا طردناه ثم بعد ذلك جعل الملك
فيصل في 72 وافتتح المسجد الكبير وقدم
مساهمات كبيره جدا لجمهوريه تشاد الفتره
الاخيره
اصبحت اصبحت التطبيع يعني حتى اذا كان من
جانب حكومي لكن الشعب التشادي وساند
القضيه الفلسطينيه
واقف مع القضيه الفلسطينيه
وما جرى حقيقه كان يوسفنا جميعا يا شباب
شادي ولا وحدي وانما نحن شابه كلنا تاسفنا
بذلك كثيرا
وان شاء الله تعالى نتمنى انه الحكومه
تشاديه تتراجع عن قرار التطبيع مع الايام
لانه ما نستطيع ان نستود اي حاجه لانه
عندما تنتظر انه اي انسان ياتي من الخارج
لكي يمولك او يستثمر في مشاريع هذا نوع من
الكسل ضرب من الكسل المفترض نحن الان
اسرائيل اذا عملت علاقه مع تشاد تطور لنا
الثروه الزراعيه تعمل انا مياه جوفيه
من سنه 1960 لدينا قدراتنا دوله تمتلك
اكبر 35 مخزون من النفط في العالم دوله
فيها مناجم الذهب في الشمال بصوره خياليه
دوله فيها يورانيوم فيها خيرات من كل
زراعي اكبر دوله تمتلك ثروه حيوانيه في
افريقيا
اكبر دوله في مياه الجوفيه في وسط افريقيا
دوله موقعها جدا استراتيجي قلب افريقيه
تربط ما بين العالم العربي والعالم
الافريقي يميننا السودان وشمالا ليبيا
غربا نيجيريا والكاميرون يعني جدا جميل
جدا يعني بوابه العالم العربي الى افريقيا
وكذلك هو تفارقه الى العرب
العرب من جهتهم هل قاموا بخطوات تقارب مع
تشاد ام انه كما تواجهون بصوره نمط الناس
يستغربون انكم عرب اساسا او انكم تتحدثون
اللغه العربيه
صراحه الحين ننصدم من هذا السؤال كثيرا هل
انتم عرب هل انتم مسلمون البعض يتعجب
وبالفعل انا لا الوم العرب في ذلك الوم
نحن نحن ما عرفنا نفسنا انت عندما تعرف
نفسك ما تنتظر من ياتي ويستكشفك لا قل انا
هكذا انا افريقي انا عربي انا هكذا فانت
عندما تقوم بتعريف ذاتك الاخرين يعني
سيكون معك اما
الدول العربيه قدمت مجالات كبيره جدا مثلا
مصر السودان نحن عندنا الان مئات الطلبه
الذين يدرسون في السودان وفي مصر مئات
الطلبه التي درسوا في الخليج ورجعوا يعني
قدموا مجهودات لكن نحن ما نقول ان هذه
المجهودات ترقى الى الكفايه لانه في
النهايه العمق الاستراتيجي للخليج وللدول
العربيه هي افريقيا يعني حاليا ذهبوا في
النهايه كيف تعود الى الدول الاعلان خاصه
القضيه الاثيوبيه قضيه اثيوبيه جعلت
العالم العربي يدرك انه كان في غفله سنوات
طويله جدا عن افريقيا الان التفت لافريقيه
وبالفعل يعني ان تصل متاخ خيرا من ان لا
تصل يعني نعم وخصوصا ان افريقيا يعني فيها
52 دوله مجموعه كبيره جزء لا باس به هي
دول عربيه او ناطقه باللغه العربيه او
فيها مجموعه عربيه يعني تستطيع ان تكون
حليف استراتيجي في الجمعيه العامه في
الامم المتحده وفي اي مؤسسات دوليه تجمع
هذه الدول اذا عدنا لملف التطبيع قليلا هل
هناك مشاهد تطبيع على الارض في داخل تشاد
كما راينا في بعض الدول العربيه التي طبعت
ام هناك
يعني هناك نوعان من التطبيع هناك التطبيع
السياسي وهناك تطبيع رايناه ملموسا في
شوارع بعض الدول العربيه للاسف كيف هو
المشهد في تشاد
يختلف يختلف جدا يعني ما في انشطه كبيره
جدا بس بعض الانشطه الخيريه اللي كانت مره
في مستشفى المستشفى الكبير في تشاد كانت
المنظمه اسرائيليه قد دعم اجهزه قلب ويعني
دعم صحي وطبي يعني قدمت له قدمت للمستشفى
عفوا وبعد ذلك ما في نشاط على المدى
الواسع وما في يعني حركه يعني حراك او
انشطه معروفه كذا انه السفاره مثلا انشطه
لا اعتقد انه اي شيء من ذلك هم بالفعل
يعني اسرائيل عندما تعمل تطبيقيه هي
رغبتها مش انها تعمل تقدم دعم لهذه الدول
هي تريد ان تكسب دعم لها في المحافل
الدوليه
فالطبيع مع هذه الدول هي لا تريد من
الشعوب شيء تريد من الحكام ان يساندوها
اذا احتجت لهم في اي وقت اما الشعوب مثلا
اذا كان هناك قرار مثلا يعينه فيه وما الى
ذلك اما الشعوب ما في لا يقدمون للشعوب اي
شيء حقيقتهم كان هناك مفاوضات
ضمت الكثير من الفصائل مؤخرا
كيف انعكست على واقع الحال في التشاد
حاليا
المفاوض تمت هنا في الدوحه وعاده الفصائل
التي موجوده كانت في الدوحه والتي كانت
خارج الدوحه عادت الى هناك وحتى الان يعني
عمليه الانتقال الديمقراطي مخاضه وعسير
ليس بالامر اليسير فحتى الان التشاديون
جميعا رغبتهم الحقيقيه انهم يريدون عداله
وتسامح ويريدون التنميه ويريدون مساواه
لانه المساواه والعداله اهم شيء يعني اهم
قيمتين الان يبحث عنها
المرحله الانتقاليه ستستمر حتى
2026 تقريبا بعدها ستكون هذا انتخابات
فحتى ذلك الحين هناك بعض الخطا المساعي
الحميده سواء من المعارضه ومن الحكومه
الحكومه امس رمضان افرقت عن اسرى جبهه
التي كانت التي تتهمها الحكومه بان اقتلت
الرئيس افرجت عنهم المعارضه ايضا عندهم
ربه في التسامح وطي صفحه الخلافه الماضي
لانه في النهايه نحن تشاهدون ما حياتي احد
اخر من الخارج ويسكن معنا وكما قال شاعرنا
الكبير حسب الله مهدي فضله تشاد بشراكه ان
الشمله ملتئم ابناءك يجتمعوا والود ضمهم
صاحوا باجمعهم لا للحروب ولا للظلم الا
بحبل الله نعتصم بلادنا اهنت بالحرب اذ
تركت تغيث منها عقودا بلو وغردم دكت
معالمنا مده ثقافتنا صرنا حديثا وقيله
حولنا التهم واليوم عانت لنا الالباب
واتضحت بفكر وزال الغير والصمم فل همه نمن
البلاد بها بالعدل والعلم يبنى الشامخ
العلم نريدها حره عظمى دعائمها سمحا تسخر
بالاخلاق والقيم نريدها حره عظمى دعائمها
بالعدل والعلم والقانون والقلم
لكن تصلح كامنيه لكل الدول العربيه التي
تشهد نزاعات وحروب للاسف الشديد يعني فعلا
كلام جميل
نهايه
ما هو الدور الذي تطمحونه له او الذي
تسعون الى ان يكون دور عربي في تحقيق هذا
الهدف الاهداف التي خرجت بها المفاوضات
حقيقه الهدف الذي خرج به المفاوضات ايكون
حضور الدول العربيه ايكون حضور الدول
العربيه من خلال موضوعين مهمين الاستثمار
والاتيام بالجانب دعم اللغه العربيه يعني
هذا الموضوع في غايه الاهميه حقيقه خاصه
انحسار اللغه الفرنسيه حاليا في افريقيا
تعرفين الان الروس دخولهم في افريقيا ما
يحدث في مالي ما يحدث في بوركينا فاسو
تداعيات ذلك على دول الساحل الدول العربيه
موقفها جدا بطيء من افريقيا يعني في خطوات
لكن خطوات جدا بطيئه نتمنى ان يكون جامعه
الدول العربيه ولا الدول العربيه
استثمارات في التشاد دعم للتعليم في تشاد
استقطاب الكفاءات التشاديه وتدريبها حتى
تعود الى تشاد وتكون قادره على مواكبه
عمليه التغيير نحن كما ذكرت لك في اللقاء
بدايه اللقاء انه عندنا اميه نسبتها 70%
اشياء الاطفال الصغار في الشمال وفي
البوادي لا يذهبون للمدارس اطلاقا لان
الحكومه حتى الان عجزت ان تقدم لهم بناء
مدارس فنحن حقيقه انا اذا اردت ان اختصر
جميع الرغبات التي تحتاجها تشاد من الدول
العربيه هي ان تدعم التعليم وان تستثمر في
مجالات مختلفه واهم استثمار يمكن ان
تستثمره هو ان تستثمر في الانسان يعني
وتشاد يعني صراحه
عندما تقرا عنها
من الاخر وقد يطردك لكن نحن ابناء الولد
نعرف تشاد يعني اهلها مرحبون طيبون فيهم
بشاشه لا يملون من الضيف اطلاقا فيهم كرم
حاتمي انت الان تجيني مثلا زياره عندي انا
مثلا اسره اسره تجلسين معنا الى ما شاء
الله من دون ان اسالك شخص متى تعودين او
متى ترجعين انت منا وفينا حتى لا بقيت عشر
سنوات عندما تريدين الرحيل ترحلين هكذا
شعب مضياف ويحب الكرم
واضيفنا لو زرتنا لوجدتنا نحن الضيوف وانت
رب المنزل
استشراف
للتبادل العربي التشادي هل انت متفائل
والله لماذا فلكن متفائلا يعني متفائل
احسن وان شاء الله تعالى يكون ان شاء الله
تعالى دور كبير جدا تلعبه تشاد ما بين
الدوله العربيه والدوله الافريقي في تشاد
حتى يكون تشات تستحق هذا الشيء يعني ان
تلعب هذا الدور تستحق ولا في كوادر كثر من
حاليا
الامين العام لمنظمه التعامل الاسلامي وهي
اكبر منظمه اقليميه اسلاميه هو اسمه
ابراهيم حسام طاهو تشاد الجنسيه تشاد
بامكان ان تلعب دور كبير جدا رئيس مفاوضات
الاتحاد الافريقي الذي يظهر الناس بلغته
العربيه واتقان وتحديثه موسى فكي محمد
ايضا يعتبر منه
ان تخرج نوابق وبامكاني ان تلعب دور رياضي
كبير جدا في تبادل العلاقات العربيه
والافريقيه ونحن عندنا شاعر اسماعيل عيسى
عبد الله يقول عن العالم العربي ويسكت اخي
مع الشرق فينا ضوء الضاد هم اهلنا والقبيل
اذا اعد من يصطفيهم عميلا فاني اذا دون شك
عميل وايثارهم ليس امرا محالا
ودادي فرنسا هو المستحيل
جميل جميل انك انت متوقع انك تخدم لي ببات
شعر صعب بعد كل اللي قلته انك تكون اول
شيء متشائم وبعدين ما تختم ببال شعره شكرا
لك فعلا كان لقاء جميل جدا شكرا لك استاذ
سعيد ابكر احمد الباحث والكاتب تشادي مؤلف
كتاب تشاد جوهره في يد فحام وفهمنا من كل
هذا الحديث لماذا هي جوهره ولماذا هي بيد
فحم شكرا لكم مشاهدينا ومستمعينا كان هذا
بعد امس
[موسيقى]